[Music]  Britney Spears has always given fans  something to talk about every time I do  it I'm just like it's fun for me and on  Saturday night during her Las Vegas  residency show she did just that  literally yep that's brick performing a  cover of Bonnie Raitt's 1991 hit showing  off her serious vocal chops  but before singing the classic smash the  singer took a moment to address the  crowd the press of the media of my  homeland you know there's it's really  crazy because one minute they tear you  down there was really horrible in the  next minute you're on top of the world  classic Britney she used a bit of cheeky  humor to get her point across I just  want to make sure I keep having you  mother I'm gonna talk about okay seems  like her strategy worked like a charm  [Applause]  [Music]